I could possibly have an allergic
reaction they could ingest it it's it's
really just a dangerous situation they
make it their business to mind your
business
if one british city wants to keep jolly
old England jolly by banning sad babies
and plaques honoring the dead are just
too depressing to read
that's what spell foreign officials told
the couple who wanted to place a
memorial plaque honoring the death of
their daughter in a city park and really
maybe fundamental but in Leawood Kansas
so is strict code enforcement when this
avid reader wanted to share his passion
with others through a little free
library he got a dose of civic literacy
nine-year-old Spencer Collins opened a
little library to share books with
others in the neighborhood but the city
bans buildings that aren't attached to
someone's home I thought why not just
get a rope enough to house a library
that's try little man but try thinking
inside the box because when it comes to
reading there's one book these guys
really love it's called the rule book we
can't ignore it we can't do that but
this time we mess with Texas we're a
school district has banned sunscreen it
just doesn't make sense parent Christie
Riggs is upset her 10 year old daughter
went on a school field trip recently and
came back sunburned turns out officials
in San Antonio's northeast Independent
School District confiscated sunscreen
from a 10 year old student who brought
it along on a field trip
why sunscreen is a toxic substance and
we simply cannot allow toxic things to
be in our schools Riggs says skin cancer
runs in her family and her father
recently died from it ensure cancer is
bad but imagine what could happen if
kids were allowed to bring sunscreen to
school could possibly have an allergic
reaction they could ingest it it's it's
really just a dangerous situation follow
the show on Twitter submit your nanny
nominees and check back next month for
more examples of busybodies when you're